so a friend of mine has a young person
his life and he wants this young person
to grow my friend feels helpless because
he feels like what kind of impact can he
have because he's not this person's
parent he's not this person you know
best friend and he feels like I can't do
anything you know I really want to help
what I can't do anything cuz I'm not his
dad you know I'm not his friend I don't
see him every day and he feels hopeless
and here's the thing the second that you
think that you can't have an impact that
you can it make a difference you lost as
soon as you abdicate responsibility you
lost the mena that you accept
responsibility that's when things start
to change that's when impact starts to
happen because we've all had people in
our lives we're just a brief experience
with them a brief encounter with them
has changed who we are whether it's
somebody at school whether it's an
advisor whether something that we've
just looked up to on youtube or on TV or
we read a book that person's thinking
changed who we are you could be that
impact on somebody else's life that
could be you and it's just accepting
responsibility but even if you can't
like even if you can't reach his turns
you can't get through to them even if
you can't get through to his his
teachers were the people in his class
you mean you can't make any kind of
break through to the people of lives you
can still have an impact you can still
have an impact by being present in that
person's life you would have a 15 minute
phone call with him daily or go see him
once a week in that brief encounter but
brief having somebody who believes in
you who sparks you who challenges you
who makes you feel like you can do
anything that makes a difference you
could be that difference as soon as you
stop blaming other people and accept
that responsibility that's when you
start to see growth that's when you
start to see momentum and I'm tired of
people complaining I'm tired of people
just placing blame on other people you
know you're tired of your country being
the way it is don't blame the
politicians
blame yourself start making a change
what are you doing to make your nation
better what are you doing to make your
city better what are you doing to make
your friends and family better what are
you doing to make your business better
what are you doing to build up the
people around you you can have an impact
as long as you believe you can have an
impact to stop placing blame start
accepting responsibility and start
getting some momentum
you